oh [ __ ]
it's a bad [ __ ]
if you ain't smoking turn this [ __ ]
camera off [ __ ]
it's Tuesday night
nobody expects nothing to go down on
Tuesday night not a night my [ __ ]
watch
Tuesday nights are the best time to get
down but the amateurs go out on Fridays
with Saturdays and get bottle service we
all know
Tuesdays Mondays Thursdays Sundays
that's a night when [ __ ] fiends go up
you might bump into a [ __ ] unwanted
[ __ ] it's tight those type of nights
[ __ ] ugly because I can't suck this
it's a Tuesday night
and quickly with the lingerie on oh stop
[Music]
he was [ __ ] up what's happening you
bad [ __ ] Tuesday night coming
at you from the Voodoo Lounge
if you're under 18 hang up now you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] suck this because
it's going deep tonight we got all the
utensils of debt
[Music]
we got the utensils of debt look at this
bam
where's the red stars oh [ __ ] what's
left of these these right there you ever
go to a restaurant you get the steak and
you get the appetizers these are
appetizers Plants Plus tonight we're
gonna eat the Petrified ones
I got this don't worry about what it is
okay it's already taken care of it you
won't even know you're eating it while
you're eating this [ __ ]
we're going deep tonight in the stamina
I'm all itchy and [ __ ] I'm ready to go
[ __ ] we got Heinekens we got weed
oh the pl of resistance
[Music]
when was the last time you saw a [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] thing oh my God
[Music]
my name is Paco I got a nickel look at
this it looks like Lee's little dick
look at that looks like a little [ __ ]
movie
oh [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] you put the
cap on top of here
[Laughter]
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with I got mushrooms that you put
together like a puzzle you know what I'm
saying
we got a little stem here for Lee you
don't want to look I gave him a baby one
look at this little baby stem I had
fully nothing
he says you don't want it tonight [ __ ]
the church people look at this I even
told me smell if you smell [ __ ] I'll
give you a thousand bucks there's
nothing on there these are grown
pharmaceutically this is the [ __ ] The
Grateful Dead did
so I'm telling you right now you want a
mushroom cake look at these little
mushrooms look at this look at this last
time I did that I couldn't remember the
ends of my sentences look at this
oh yeah then you like this that's kind
of the whole thing yeah anything like
this you go
nice to see you man
that's how much of a gentleman I am when
Kate comes in the mushroom goes
and a A Farewell to do to you too look
at it looks like a [ __ ] wig this is a
headpiece do you eat the whole thing no
we [ __ ] look at it and say it songs
Weird everything I ate a little bite on
here all right close that door real
quick
watch this let me show you how it's done
bang that wall twice
all the Joey Diaz picture up
from the bottom from the bottom
you're serious yeah
oh my God what the [ __ ] you think you're
doing
nothing came out
[Music]
nothing's there I put the top I found it
put the top back on
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with
no no no no I'll pick up leaves
[Music]
put your hand on the bottom
let's see if the Colombian delivered see
what I'm saying what the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with here
he was here today guys second I learned
he well he'd get into anyway
he get into any of my phone go up there
say hello
can you [ __ ] believe that you know
how we do it you know how we do it happy
birthday and [ __ ] from the church and
the Colombian oh [ __ ]
[Music]
gotta open up the [ __ ] show strong
tonight
200
you do what you want
you do what you want you bad
[ __ ]
we're gonna get this party started soon
a little ultimate Center album there
whatever the [ __ ] it is
before we get the party started this
Heinekens for you I stopped and got some
Heinekens for you you have to lose your
[ __ ] mind Lena
I don't know if we have mixer though
yeah you have tonic that tonic is 12
years old I brought this cup soda here
okay done done
[Music]
if you ain't blowing them like that let
me ask you something did you blow
bubbles as a kid
he's back in town he wants your number
you know what I'm saying
I still got it [ __ ] I still got
him on a Tuesday night I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm coming at you where's those
edible sleep
where's that four pack
it's time to go deep in the cave of
death
couple Stars couple [ __ ] hello
tushies and what is that two nights left
in [ __ ] in Hanukkah
that's it that's it when did Hanukkah
strong you understand me we ain't
[ __ ] around here you want to [ __ ]
around go hang out with your little
[ __ ] friends we're going deeper than
deep you might as well call me Jack
Cousteau because we ain't [ __ ] around
tonight
bam look at that
I told you this stars with a pair of
teeth
[Music]
like that let the intestines do the work
you understand me
a little water cause you always want to
stay hydrated when you're [ __ ] around
with Edibles or any other [ __ ] drugs
you don't want your [ __ ] kidneys to
dry out them they get sent to the
hospital you call me up Joey would I go
wrong where'd you go wrong you didn't
drink no [ __ ] water
foreign
[Music]
this is beautiful right there
I'm telling you he's he's
scared look at Lee dropping knowledge
Wicked lead dropping knowledge on Kate
the hook quickly get over here
[ __ ] yeah once you see her ass
you're hooked you know what I'm saying
once you see cake Quigley's [ __ ] ass
with your bikini on your hook that's it
you quit acting class you call home for
more money
I'm calling off Ma I met this girl
an acting class
she knows people
she's been sexually harassed
[Music]
ready for a bucket
Harley shirt on his [ __ ]
and [ __ ] look he dressed up for cake
lately tonight oh [ __ ] yeah
he went to DXL
they got a new shirt for mama
[Music]
I got this on Amazon
[Music]
the mule is kicking
[Music]
beautiful Blends insane that's from the
Iranian he grew at his backyard with
tomatoes
okay
that's the way we're doing it tonight
people I'm allergic to Iranians you know
what I'm saying
if you're under 18 hang up now you
little [ __ ] suckers I know you're
sitting around waiting for Santa Claus
you're bored I'm the wrong I'm the wrong
Santa you know what I'm saying I bring
you nothing but aggravation
bring you nothing but aggravation
and [ __ ] pain
but I bring the goods on my Judas Priest
and help bet for leather delivering the
goods you follow me that's all that
matters
you crack this [ __ ] open
[Music]
oh my God
I don't [ __ ] around you know what I'm
saying when I was swinging I was
swinging that's what I was getting
that's from the cartel you following me
yeah you don't [ __ ] around it when I was
swinging I was swinging I wasn't doing
this [ __ ] [ __ ] power that selling
now giving people rashes and [ __ ]
I was getting it right off the block
that's how I roll you follow me
so when you want to see the Colombian
you [ __ ] call me on this side and you
go Joey I'm deep deep deep
I want the [ __ ] they were doing on Sons
of Anarchy and that's it I deliver the
goods that's how we do it do I have
dates I got nothing I got no dates I
don't want to do comedy for a while I'm
just relaxing you follow me I'm relaxing
smoking dope and being a family man I
don't give a [ __ ] about anything else
jokes I don't give a [ __ ] TJ Miller got
busted today another one
Jesus
nobody [ __ ] knows that he knocked on
the door he [ __ ] her in the ass he put
a bottle in the [ __ ]
just like the guys I love
that's tremendous Kate thank you for
putting the Dapper on my heart
he punches you he bites you
those guys are crazy I don't mind
[ __ ] going crazy on somebody but you
gotta be [ __ ] uh doing drugs to do
that craziness
I send my heart out to DJ I don't
believe dick you know me go
you didn't call the cop you know I don't
believe it
I'm sorry I think that way but in
today's society everybody's [ __ ]
can't wait to call the cops everybody
can't wait to call the cops if you yell
at them they can't wait to call the cops
I'm calling 9-1-1 this is harassment so
so what's the problem here you follow me
I smoke another bonding because that's
what we're here to do what do you think
about the body from a deep sleep to
[ __ ] tell you fairy tales
who knows I don't know why you go to
sleep so early maybe you're bored maybe
you know you're sick and tired of
[ __ ] doing your thing
do you believe we're all the animals
we got some more [ __ ] Killers over
here oh shitly
your lucky [ __ ] day look at you a
bunch of yardsticks
[Music]
[Music]
you're going deep tonight this is it I
won't see you till [ __ ] and next week
we're going deeper I got the nurse with
doing Chinese heroin it's clean
you're not serious [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
right from the tongues you know what I'm
saying we ain't [ __ ] around you're
getting delivered in a helicopter
and I can't shoot it I just do a little
line with leak
and there's a little line
[Music]
this is no well you can Detroit you got
the uh Isis heroin that's why it's seven
dollars
[Music]
we ain't scared enough we don't give a
[ __ ] about nothing he's Jewish you
understand me yeah he's one of those
Harvey Weinstein dungeon juice either
you suck his dick or you suck his dick
something's always gonna happen you
follow me
[Music]
No More Tears [ __ ] suckers you're here
with your Uncle Joey a couple weeks
couple days before Christmas
you got a couple days left in the year
to get your [ __ ] together
write your goals your expectations and
what you want to happen next year and
see what happens look at that list in
June and get back to me you're gonna go
Joey you're a [ __ ] fortune teller no
I lived it write down what you want how
you're going to do it three things how
you gonna do it how are you gonna get
there and go back in June you're gonna
come out here and [ __ ] secular harass
me that's how happy you're gonna be
you're gonna be like Terry Crews you're
gonna you're gonna grab the cue when
they're growing but I'm gonna call the
cops on you [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] was the cops and somebody
grabs your dick some of you guys my dick
I throw a parade you know what I'm
saying I give out hamburgers like John
Gotti on the fourth of July I don't give
a [ __ ] Jack nobody grabs your dick
who grabs your dick nobody what the [ __ ]
it's a party somebody grab maybe you
were standing under the [ __ ] triple
weave what's that thing
mistletoe whatever the [ __ ] it is mango
weed
what if you what if you're standing
under a mistletoe and I don't want to
kiss you maybe maybe you're standing on
the mistletoe you got a [ __ ] missing
tooth and I just want to stick a finger
up your ass is that sexual harassment
get back to me
everything goes under the mistletoe you
know what I'm saying you can lick a
click you can light [ __ ] heads on
fire stay away from the door just in
case the D.A is driving by you know what
I'm
saying
yeah
they do Rounds Around Here I saw a D.A
on bicycles around here knocking on
doors have you seen any suspicious
individuals no I have not
as a matter of fact
but Uncle Joey sparking you want to see
my license
I got everything I got Ebola I got
everything I got every [ __ ] I thought I
got fungi toenail I got everything
so get it together officer get out of my
front [ __ ] Butch you know I love you
[ __ ] the FBI I know you're
watching I got you
I got you since I was a kid I used to
see you around the corners creeping and
[ __ ] like perverts and those [ __ ]
cars you don't think I saw you but I saw
you with your cameras and with your
parabolic microphones get it together
get it together
give them a freeze don't give them a
black give them a little freeze please
some guy it's like going to dinner
put on your dick a sexual harassment
on your dick
and rub it on that little [ __ ] noodle
it's all over you know what I'm saying
but anyway we're back with queer we're
here one more bondingly what do you
think
you can't walk on one leg you know what
I'm
saying
who the [ __ ] are you kidding me you
wanna look at this jaw look at these
goodies in here this is some pretty
[ __ ] bud
given to me by a nice gentleman
a little Mexican look at this
look at this one here
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yes it is that's what Kate said
that's a big little league little
[ __ ]
you a little [ __ ] very surprising
what can I say Lisa Savage you're dead
oh no no he's on he's a polo shirt
s
he told his [ __ ] girlfriend not to
come home
don't even come home I might bring you I
might bring cat over here you know what
I'm saying okay
so don't even come over here and [ __ ]
[Music]
some Benedito
[Music]
in the bush there you go there you go
that's the one that's the one that's the
one
tremendous tremendous
we're making it happen here at the
Voodoo Lounge tonight on a Tuesday night
the only thing that's missing is you you
bad [ __ ]
anyway where's the nurse where's The Who
the nurse the nurse is coming don't
worry about nothing I got the wrong call
she'll be here in two minutes if we need
to she's around the corner she's
Filipino she's a little Filipina chick
she'll be here in two minutes in the
Rickshaw she brings she brings the
pigeons everything it's a [ __ ] party
when that nurse shows up
who's driving the Rickshaw I don't know
her uncle I don't know I didn't ask you
know what I'm saying don't ask no
questions
and that's it and that's that you bet
[ __ ]
you know it's never a dull moment here
why because that's how we like it
if we're going to give you a show
we're gonna give you a [ __ ] show your
phone
what's the matter lady making noises
lungs overrated you know what I'm saying
plums over here
who [ __ ] needs them to get you in
trouble they get yeah
oh yeah the other day oh in Periscope
yeah it's like he's outside yay
which store did you walk through
find a grocery store what'd you get uh
yes I just got mail we're back you
follow me why I don't [ __ ] know why
because that's how we made it happen
I'm happy you checked in
I'm happy to stick around for a few
[ __ ] minutes here
anyway it doesn't matter I thought I'd
heard something
the mushrooms already kicking in
this race that's how we wanted it
yes you do
yeah shut up you guys what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you anyway
youtube.com C slash Joey Diaz is the
place to be you bad [ __ ] why I
don't know but if you're gonna sit there
binge watching some [ __ ] [ __ ] show
you might as well come over to the
church and take a chance you follow me
why I don't know again
I don't I don't know just take a chance
take a chance Columbus did why not come
hang out with Uncle Joe youtube.com
slash C slash Joey Diaz because I love
you Lee's here Kate's here [ __ ]
Tito's here
this is our yearly Christmas podcast and
[ __ ] spreading cheer and all that
[ __ ] Kate's got a story about her
last [ __ ] party in Vegas
so youtube.com C slash Joey Dizz I love
you [ __ ] with all my heart what
is this that stands before me